i had envisioned being a 21 year old
millionaire if you ask my 17 year old
self
and uh nothing could be farther from a
reality
but um but i wouldn't have it any other
way from from this
standpoint first of all congratulations
not one but two grammy nominations this
year right out the gate
uh i mean have you had is it crazy to
think that just two years ago
i mean cardi b and chance the rapper
were judging you on
rhythm and flow and they know a thing or
two about getting some love from the
grammys but
has it sunk in yet yes sunk in because
the work is real you know so
we've been putting in work for a long
time to get to this point and to
maintain
a platform like this it takes a lot of
work and commitment so that part is
really grounded but
you know to get recognized for this is
for sure it's something worth
you know celebrating and it wasn't that
long ago that cardi and chance in
particular
won best rap album so it's kind of like
a not only
full circle moment but obviously this
has been a long road to the grammys for
you in a long musical journey and
someone who had a big part of that i
know was your mom
what was her reaction when you scored
these nominations from the recording
academy my mom is better at celebrating
my achievements than i am you know what
i'm saying so i take it all in stride
but she really you know
if i want to get emotional and get
worked up i just look at my mom's face
and then i'm like all right mom don't do
that too you know because she feels
everything for you
absolutely absolutely you know cause you
know she made sacrifices
so that i could have these opportunities
you know she she's a brilliant musician
herself
and having three boys really young she
just
you know decided to prioritize being a
mother and and teaching us everything
she knew
which ended up being like our advantage
in studio and
in uh in our in our endeavors i heard
that you guys get to
take one person with you to the grammys
uh who's your date can i assume it's
your mom
yeah mom is my date that's mommy's my
day yeah she oh
because she's also on the song black
habits one of the biggest songs off my
project you know
she's rightfully the person that i'm i'm
taking with i bet she's stoked too did
she have a dress picked out
yes she does well no i'm not picked out
it's custom-made so
there you go what a special night you
guys are about to have that's so awesome
you know you've worked with and have
learned from a lot of mentors a lot of
people who have been nominated for
grammys before
have you heard from anybody has anyone
give you any advice as a first-time
nominee
not so much advice but just getting
congrats from snoop dogg hit me up you
know what i'm saying of course
a lot of different people hit me up and
you know close friends and family
from englewood just reaching out and let
me know they proud it just means a lot
you know the ones that
that mean the most are the ones from
home you know
because they feel like they're on that
platform when they see me up there so
that's
that's dope the people like the ones who
have already had that the people who
have reached the pinnacles of rap music
and music in general snoop dogg
that's really dope too because it's like
to get recognized by your peers is
something special
so it's both it's two different feelings
but they're both nice well it's also
crazy when your peers
become you know your idols become peers
people you looked up to
right absolutely i'm curious what do the
kids that you taught spanish
to say about your success the first
thing they say is pura vida
you know so when i was when i was uh
when i was teaching spanish that was my
agreement with them like every time i
would come into class after i took role
and all that i would
they knew class was about to start when
i'd be like say
every message that i get is it starts
off with pura vida senora faris and all
that yeah
and you know of course that's from my
little uh study abroad experience in
costa rica and
and some things that culture taught me
so it's beautiful too
for them to see me there and have real
life memories you know because
to the rest of the world it's the story
to them it's like no we saw him every
day for
at least a year some people some
students had me two years consecutive
you know so
i love that you just set the vibe right
every class that's what you're going to
do with in your whole life i could tell
got to you got to set the vibe that's
right well before you won rhythm and
flow
i know you were writing and producing
for others
like i mentioned you know you have been
pounding pavement and worked really hard
to this moment what about your journey
has surprised you the most and has it
been what you expected the thing about
my
journey that surprised me the most is
that it happened so quickly after so
much time
right so even after a long time that's
it took me developing the patience to do
it day in day out by myself
and at that when i was determined to do
it that way when i was determined to
take the lung right it happened right
away all the times in my 20s when i was
trying to make it happen right away
it took forever so that was just the
irony of the situation
like even i think pharrell said in the
interview years and years ago it took
him
10 years to blow up overnight and i was
it took me 15 to blow up overnight you
know
do you feel like do you feel like that's
humbling like do you feel like it's
shaped your perception of like the music
industry
absolutely i i had envisioned being a 21
year old millionaire if you ask my 17
year old self
and uh nothing could be farther from a
reality
but i wouldn't have it any other way
from from this standpoint
were the grammys on your vision board
like was that like a pipe dream for you
absolutely what's crazy is i always saw
myself on the grammys for having
produced something or having written
something for somebody else like
initially my dream wasn't to be a star
or to be famous
it was to be the mastermind behind a lot
of music that people listen to
and still is you know to be in this
position for my own music and to be able
to have a voice
of my own is something really special
outside of the music as well because you
know in our interview spaces people are
interested
in the story in the man behind the music
which is very cool
well you have such an amazing story and
i feel like you have
also such a bright future ahead i really
am here because i believe
you really are the future of black music
john legend said that you
are shaping the future of black music
now when you hear that from an artist
that is so respected like john legend
what does that mean to you
it means everything i try to limit my
fan
moments when i come across the john
legends and the snoop doggs
i know so many of his lyrics i just knew
that that was one of those artists that
i was gonna
listen to entire projects like i love a
lot of music from different people but i
i tend to pick my songs as a lot of
music listeners do but when he first
came out i really paid attention to
entire projects song for song so when he
says that it's
it's kind of like that we share a common
cloth in and how we approach music how
we
experience music and how we want to
share with the world
you have sighted you know rappers like
snoop dogg and like outcast some of your
biggest
influences it's one thing to be
influenced by them it's another to work
with them and collaborate with them
are they on that list though are those
like dudes you want to work with
eventually
absolutely absolutely um huge outcast
fan
um i've worked with snoop dogg snoop was
on my uh
one of my singles from the last project
gasparinga
and um he pulled up in inglewood and
shot a video in the middle of inglewood
you know and um
it was just a big it was a big moment
because you know one
anybody who knows the streets knows
snoop and englewood
there's there's an inherent difference
in territory but
being snoop dogg he has so much love
across all of
those boundaries that people would
assume prevent how he can move
so um it was just so much love he pulled
up in my city shot the video
and uh and gave me some game in the in
the middle of that whole process you
know he
he told me i'm gonna show you how to
build your legacy like you got success
already now
it's about building the legacy your
thoughts on west coast sound
why do you feel like it's important to
you know keep that sound thriving and
also do you feel like it's evolved at
all since
when you were growing up oh absolutely
uh the west coast sound has evolved
um the west coast is super influenced by
funk
you know what i'm saying you got that
stump that stump sound that uh
that battle cat used to incorporate into
a lot of um
a lot of snoop records and you know the
dog pound records and things like that
and then now you know with you know
things like the jerk movement and all
that it kind of picked up the tempo and
all that stuff and it's
right now at a place where um it
combines all that but
what what i think the west coast
uniquely contributed to music
is that um is this musicianship behind
everything right
um what people don't know about the west
coast there's this big like uh
there's a big movement where a lot of
these church musicians find their way
into the studios
and produce on the record so you have
this very gospel influenced
still gangsta sound and music that
that you can hear in a lot of the greats
of west coast music from
ice cube mac 10 dr dre snoop
kendrick lamar and you know that i like
to carry into my music as well
i do put myself under a lot of pressure
to
uh to perform to put myself in this
space where
i can um hear hear new original creative
ideas
and so that takes a lot of discipline in
my personal life just to
tune out the things that might distract
me from what what i'm supposed to say
and then um and then in terms of what i
would say for
any kid that wants to pursue music or
whatever their dream is
i would just say uh give yourself time
and continue studying
and always be open to growing and um
and you know things things do happen for
the people that put into work